What do you think about adding hydrogen water to my cancer protocol? Do you know?
If this is a good brand and the person I think shared a link that I did that I'm not aware of so I don't know if that was a good brand now
Hydrogen water I have and people have asked this question somebody asked this question this recently
I don't think there's any downside to adding hydrogen water. I will say that
There's been some data on hydrogen water that it can function as an
anti-oxidant but I'm not sure that that's correct data
All that I've seen about hydrogen water to be has benefits it increases the oxygenation of the water
There is a bottle out there. I think it's W E I if you just search W E I
Hydrogen water. I think you'll come to their website a
Doctor who used to work for me some of you might remember her Dr. Kelly Holderman
I have some of her videos still on our site somewhere. She used to work for me for a number of years
This was a number of years ago
Gosh, it's been like maybe six years since she worked for me, but I still have good relationship with her and such she became
The doctor that was
For that brand W E I hydrogen water and she was a
Representative of theirs or she she was kind of the face of the company. I don't know if she still is I haven't talked her for what a year or so
But it was I researched it at the time and it seemed like a good company and it seemed like a
In inexpensive way overall if you're gonna stick with using hydrogen water to use it because it's a it's the you buy the bottle
And it basically is making the hydrogen water by electrolysis of the water
The bottle itself you have to charge with a USB port like every five days or something and you just fill it up with water
You turn it on and it
Electrolysis the water to split the hydrogen and oxygen molecules
So it helps to oxygenate the water and you get hydrogen from the water not just the H2O
As a combined molecule, so it has different benefits to your body now the bottle was like
I don't 250 bucks or something like that. That's like that's a lot of money
But if you're gonna get the hydrogen tablets to you make hydrogen water
That's the other option is you put these hydrogen these tablets in your in a bottle of water and you shake it and let it sit for
A minute or something and then you drink it that adds up to I mean obviously it's a lot less expensive
But when you add that up you could be spending $30 a month of that so it seems like if you're going to make a long term commitment to hydrogen water getting that we model
W.E.I. might be a good idea
But if you just want to try it we have the H2 tablets you could purchase on our store
I don't remember how much they are but it seems like they're like a dollar a tablet or something like that
So you'll spend $30 a month if you're just doing one you know one model of it every day
So I don't make anything off the W.E.I. product. You have to go to their website and stuff and look that up but
There's something to look at. I don't see it as a downside. I don't see it as a necessity though either
I do know that there I do think that the reason why people have asked this question in recent
Days is because there's just there's a lot of influencers on
Instagram and Facebook I just saw a doctor Guthrie and about hydrogen water. Okay, so
Just remember a lot of the influencers influencers will push things because they're selling something
And you know they have no
Downside to
Telling people to purchase something because they're not in practice anymore
And you can't be in trouble for making recommendations that are unworthy
So just keep that in mind many things are overhyped oversold out there in the influencer
Instagram Facebook TikTok world. So just keep that in mind
And keep that in mind even when you see a video nine like the question before on turkey tail
That's a great that's a great product. I love turkey tail
But doesn't mean everybody needs it
You know because you could watch a whole bunch of videos of mine and like oh, I need to take this I need to take this
I need to take this no, I'm just talking about the wonderful thing about
IP6
It's a great product etc
But it's not for everybody. That's why we do the cheek swab test or the ones you'll be taking a hundred different things
So you read my book. I probably talk about a hundred different
Nutraceuticals for cancer. Are we going to take all those? No, of course we're not
That's why we do the cheek swab test so you don't have to take all those
But of course if you're thinking about something and you're praying about something
The God puts something on your heart. You really feel led that you should do that then by all means
You know, I asked the question first so that you're not taking something that some influencers
led you down a path that is wrong but
But um, you know by all means if you feel led to do something then go ahead and do it but
You so much you doing so much that
It can harm you because you remember too much of a good thing can be a man thing so just keep that in mind